[Musique]
c'est au service départemental
d'incendie et de secours du port que la
ministre Dominique Faure est venue
saluer les sapeurs-pompiers de la
caserne un site sensible qui rassemble
une quarantaine de professionnels
spécialisés dans les secours à la
personne les incendies les risques
naturels mais aussi les risques
technologiques et industriels ici sur
l'île de la Réunion que les risques sont
très très nombreux de plein de natures
différentes et que il faut beaucoup de
dons de soi beaucoup d'engagement
beaucoup de compétences pour arriver à
secourir
nos concitoyens donc je les ai beaucoup
encouragés beaucoup félicité remercier
je vois que les infrastructures suivent
le déconseil départemental
a vraiment fait de gros efforts à la
fois un investissement et un
fonctionnement donc je repars de cette
visite avec une confiance dans l'équipe
à la fois qui dirige et qui animent et
qui travaillent dans ceci doté de
matériel d'intervention adaptée aux
différents risques c'est
sapeurs-pompiers peuvent intervenir sur
tous les terrains la ministre délégué
chargé des collectivités territoriales
et de la ruralité ainsi échangé avec
l'équipe nautique les secours en milieu
périlleux et montagne et l'équipe du
service Santé et de ce cours médical
ensemble ils réalisent plus de 3000
interventions chaque année nous avons
S10 qui est au fil des années ce
professionnalisme et nous avons joué une
capacité d'intervention qui est quand
même remarquable avec des femmes et des
hommes professionnels dévoués à
disposition de la population pour
intervenir dans les meilleures
conditions mais aussi du matériel et des
équipements mais aussi des casernes qui
sont là avec des financements du
département pour permettre à nos équipes
d'intervenir donc je salue le dévouement
et le professionnalisme des
sapeurs-pompiers les pompiers de cette
caserne font partie du service
départemental d'incendie et de secours
de la Réunion qui rassemble au total
plus de 865 sapeurs-pompiers
professionnels et 1465 sapeurs-pompiers
volontaires tous rassemblés au sein des
28 Centres d'Incendie et de Secours
répartis sur l'ensemble du territoire
[Musique]